[Music]
you are listening
to inside of you with michael rosenbaum
hi i hope you're doing well it's uh
it's not been an easy week for me
i try to be positive uh so i know
a lot of you are having maybe a tough
week tough time
maybe you're having a great time i hope
you are
um so ryan i hate to throw this on you
but um
i gotta put my doggy down
yeah i gotta put i gotta put herb down
it's uh it's the hardest decision i've
ever made
and you know uh i based it on two things
one quality of life his quality of life
he can
he can't walk and if he does he just is
dragging
he can't i have to hold him up to go to
the bathroom to poop
um you could hear him whining uh
his life is just not great it's it's bad
i don't like it i don't think it's fair
number two uh there's no
getting better he's only gonna get worse
he's only gonna decline doctors are like
this is only going to get worse and
worse and worse and
i just hate watching him like this he
was such a vivacious
you know creature ran around and jumped
on people and
and just was so full of life and it's
just like his existence
other than me hugging him and feeding
him is [ __ ]
so i had my friend shira come over and
shira is a big uh
she's vaccinated don't worry i'm
vaccinated too
so are you well getting there getting
there but she came over and
and i thought she was gonna say no no
he's he's because she's always like you
know trying to save dogs
and she was like it's time and i was
like oh wow
she didn't even hesitate i've called
everybody and i'm having someone come to
the house
this doctor who my friend alex
recommended
um comes to the house and is just sweet
as hell and it's a nice service and
you know they take the dog and you know
you get the ashes and stuff
and uh it's overwhelming and i'm like
this but you just
and you sometimes you look oh wait a
minute he's he's having a better day
today uh
and then he has it's just back and forth
like
you know and i go well can i change it
if the day
if she goes absolutely if you decide you
you could change them
i'm thinking oh my god let's push this
wednesday let's push the thursday let's
push
you know what let's give it another week
i'm not going to do that i think that
it's it's just time it's just not
fair and uh i you know
my grandpa irv died at 94 years old
and irv really is 94 years old he's 13
plus which is in dog years so it's 13
times 7 is 91
plus add six months of before we got him
when you're six months so
you know it's like uh i'm just hoping
you know
my grandfather will see irv wherever
they are
and irv will go my grandfather because
earth can't talk to dog
i'll say what the hell is this what are
you doing here
he always said that to her what is he
doing already why did you name him nerve
he's uh
yeah you're supposed to wait till i die
before you name your dog after me
but uh anyway it's a tough thing so i
want to and i want to say thank you to
there's so many
hundreds and hundreds of messages all
across
the boards of just you know just kind
words
and they know how much i loved her all
my patrons i love you i love you thank
you for all of them
you know like sweet sassy mary said i'll
be sending you extra loving vibes as
uh you say goodbye to irv give blanche
some extra lovin
she'll miss him too remember sassy miss
mary loves you
and i thought that was really kind um
kelly stevenson just sending you words
of encouragement
or it means the world to you praying for
you as you grieve over the loss
uh so you know i got a lot of messages
and it was uh it was really sweet
um leanne thank you i mean thank you to
everybody emily i mean i could
there's a list that i can go on and on
but uh it was really it's
nice to see people just saying hey you
know because people you know they go
through this have you gone through it
have you lost to
put down a dog i mean we talked about
this before
um yeah i mean we drove
that's right yeah the one time and we've
had to put down dogs but um
that's rough man i'm sorry yeah he's
just family i'm having
like a a service where people come over
on sunday and they just say goodbye to
irv and just give him a hug and
and then monday we do it so i'm gonna
spoil him this weekend and give him
anything he wants ice cream and
uh but it's time man unless there's some
miracle where he wakes up and he
there's a new irv uh so anyway i've been
it's been tough but and i also want to
say sorry to rob
robert brandenburg peggy's coffee in
texas where i get my coffee
uh for not saying your name at the end
of each show all the top-tier patrons i
say their names and uh for some reason i
didn't so i'm gonna blame bryce bryce if
you're listening you son of a [ __ ]
now you know uh also thank you marissa
monterello sent me a a nice note and
sent me an uh
a trilogy of alien of all these pictures
of the movies from alien the alien
trilogy
it's actually more than a trilogy if
it's how many trilogies three isn't it
that's three yeah well there was like
six movies wasn't there so whatever
thank you it's awesome um listen we had
a great podcast today before i do of
course
i'm just asking if you're here for howie
and uh
you've never listened to the podcast
before it'd be really awesome if you
to on youtube it's free and apple
podcast and spotify
um you can do that you can go to youtube
ryan uh yeah youtube.com
inside of you with michael rosenbaum uh
twitter
inside of instagram facebook at inside
of you podcast
that's very simple also sun spin sun
spin
my band here you go see the shirt the
logo sun spin
is pretty awesome and uh merch 15
off we're doing 15 off just go to
sunspin.com type in sunspin15
we haven't done any uh discounts and
we're doing sunspin 15 there's already
been tons of uh
uh purchases and things like that so go
to sunspin.com
hats lunch boxes shirts uh
autographs all that stuff and type in
sunspin 15 you get 15
off and of course the inside of you
store um
we have uh we have uh only 30 available
but bryce thought it would be fun
for sale 30 fanny packs
inside of you fanny packs they're only
there's only 30 of them
so when they're gone they're gone i i
don't assume we'll be
getting more it's possible but uh ryan
put it on so you'll you might see that
on twitter
he he uh yeah here it is thank you
so it's a it's an inside you fanny pack
you could just put your uh
candy in your keys and you can put
other things in here and you put your
fanny pack on it's a nice lovable fanny
pack
but you go to an inside of you store
inside of you
uh store and uh tons of stuff lex luthor
pictures small little lunch boxes uh
shirts uh inside of you shirts pictures
uh
everything you could imagine and that's
inside of your store
also hey guys if you haven't heard the
band yet play
we're playing on april 24th it's the
last saturday of the month go to
stageit.com
also you can go to sunspin.com to book
us for zooms or
shows or whatever you want there's gonna
be a discount on zooms as well
um but to watch us live on stage at
stageit.com type in sunspin get your
ticket
we have so much fun we play covers we
play originals we play songs from left
on laurel
uh it's a blast and uh rob and i will be
jamming
and we have a brand new setup so we made
the sound better the video quality
better
we're we're technologically advancing
ourselves
all right this next guest is uh so open
about his ocd
he's so open about everything his just
anxiety
i i couldn't believe how open he was i
was almost nervous
in the beginning to ask him certain
questions and he opened up and just the
floodgates opened what did you think
oh yeah he he's a floodgatey uh open
person
and those stories they they go and
they're really interesting
what great stories howie mandel has you
know i was listening to howard stern
and um arsenio hall was on
and they were saying he was like who was
really hard to go after
doing stand-up comedy is it was it hard
to go after
sam kinnison or eddie murphy and he goes
howie mandel man he's like wait what
hallie mandela man he crushed going up
after how he was like
death he always was just crushing the
audience just loved him
so please listen please subscribe and
i love you and let's get inside of howie
mandel it's my
point of view you're listening to inside
of you
with michael rosenbaum
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience hey thanks for coming on what
does that say hi
i like goats goats do you like goats
um you know i like everything until i
dislike them
um yeah i do like goats i've never had a
no pun intended to run in with a goat i
i
though once i tried that uh i tried that
goat yoga
did you ever try that no have you heard
of it i've i
i think i have but i i barely do any
yoga so goat yoga is not no
i don't do yoga either but and and how
do you think you've heard of goat yoga
like you
either heard of it like in passing
somebody said something
i remember somebody saying something
about goat yoga but i never like pursued
to
i never i don't want to knock uh
i do want to knock it it was the
stupidest thing i first i don't do yoga
but and i'm not knocking yoga i think
everything that helps
anything that helps anybody is is
positive
but it just seems like we'll buy into
like
so they they brought a goat and and the
goat was standing on my back
and there's a a goat on you a goat is
it's got who
hooves ooze or hooves are you talking
like george jefferson kind of the
opening of the jefferson's when
the guy's on his back but there's a goat
on your back you know what i'm talking
about the jeffersons and then the other
i know the jeffersons but i don't
remember in the opening that he was
doing
yoga i know the neighbor was standing on
his back
so he's like you know massaging his back
yes yes so i was thinking
is it the same thing with a goat um
maybe i've never had a
neighbor standing on my back but the
point is that there's never
i have never been anywhere where i went
you know what i need i just need
something uncomfortable standing on my
back let alone
something that could possibly uh take a
dump and
you know they're not trained no in yoga
they're not
yogi's they're goats i had a [ __ ]
goat on my back
a goat should be in a field there's no
field on my back so that's
i forget what the question was but i i i
didn't like
yoga i didn't go back to goat yoga i
like goats i don't want to do yoga with
them
good well you've made that clear thanks
and i appreciate that i appreciate your
openness and your honesty
i i look at you as someone who it's like
i was getting i have i suffer from you
know
i get anxiety i depression i got you i'm
colorblind we can talk about that like
you are
and there's like a lot of things and
then i look at your life and i'm like
going this guy
does everything and with all this other
stuff
how does he even go how does he even
function how does he not always freaking
out an ocd on top of it
so i know we're just getting right into
it but i look at all the stuff you do
and i'm like how do you do all this [ __ ]
without freaking out
well you're assuming that it's without
freaking out you know because
thank god we're in a business that's uh
that has the capability
post-production edit my life is
basically edited
um it's really really hard and
but i kind of my analogy is you know
i have a passion for a lot of things
that i do for most of what i do
outside of uh like in in the industry
um and i think like if you have a
passion for
you know boxing if that's your thing uh
you know you can't you can't be a boxer
and
not you know suffer you know a hit in
the face
exhaustion uh being knocked out knocked
down
i feel like i'm in that fight for my
life each and every day but i'm enjoying
that game
of life but it hurts is is
you know or even the stuff that i do
have a passion for like stand-up comedy
and things like that
my uh analogy for that is um
the ability i love roller coasters i
love
thrill rides you know i'm a junkie for
it and i i figured out why and i'll get
into that
in a second but i the higher something
is the scarier it is
the faster it is the closer i think i've
come to death
the more exciting it is as anybody who
goes on a
a roller coaster you you know you could
have a roller coaster that had no hills
and a nice breeze
and you just like floated along at eight
miles an hour i don't know that you
jump off on the other side go we got to
go on again but adrenaline
you know there's nothing that brings you
into the now
and the only place i can survive is in
the
in the now you know the the problem that
we all have
in life is uh
we very rarely focus on
boom now we talk about like that's what
we're talking about we're talking about
things in the past
we're talking about things i'll do in
the future we're really not
dealing with now and we don't deal with
now and i need to be brought into now
whether it's on stage and not knowing
what i'm gonna say next
whether it's on a roller coaster and in
those moments i'm in the moment and i
can't worry about oh my god what did i
do before
and how am i gonna am i in trouble for
what i did
or i'm not in a i'm not in a frame of
mind where i can go
oh this is probably gonna happen in a
minute or in the future
you know so then i don't worry about
that and that's why
now is the imperative and that's the
only place that i can survive
is is now but that's the only thing
that's real
that's strength though because you don't
even realize that that is because
adrenaline can
is a good thing i love roller coasters
too i love
you know but sometimes as roller
coasters really like you know i would
take out that one turn that kind of hurt
i didn't like that little twist right
there it was uncomfortable
i felt like i could die right there i
didn't like it i didn't enjoy it i wish
it wasn't there
but you can't you can't do that in real
life things just come up and it's like
they're twists and turns
so have you ever had i mean look
obviously you get uncomfortable on stage
sometimes or maybe you just don't
anymore you've done it so long but
to me i look to be uncomfortable my
discomfort
is comfort when i'm uncomfortable it
brings me in the moment it's kind of
like that little pinch to see whether
you're dreaming you know what i mean i
need that
discomfort i'm not saying it's pleasant
i'm not saying my ride on a roller
coaster
is is pleasant i don't want it to be
pleasant and there are things like if
you're in the middle of the
best fight of your life as i bring you
back to that analogy that i started with
with fighting
you're gonna get hit in the face so that
is that corner that you didn't like
that's that moment that you didn't like
there's no way to kind of think
about and embrace each moment be afraid
of the next moment be afraid of what
happened
hate what just happened do it those are
all real feelings that each and every
one of us share
the problem is that for me mentally i
focus on all those moments
i just need to be in the now and deal
with it
oh well how the f can we swear on my
podcast
it's yours i don't give a [ __ ]
how how the [ __ ] do we stay present
though that's th that's the gift that
you have you can be
no it's not a gift i can't i'm you know
i'm medicated i
i i go through therapy but i i contend
that the human species you know we don't
use our strength
and our strength is i think that kind of
separates us from the animal kingdom
is instinct you know and we do have an
instinct
and when you kind of operate and none of
us really do
operate on your instinct you'll probably
do really well
instinctually you know you know what you
want to do you know what you should do
you know what you're going to do
and you do it but what happens is a lot
of us will have an idea
or something we want to do but don't
don't rush it
let me think about what the
possibilities are i better not
do that you know because this could
happen better this could happen or
i shouldn't do it because you know the
last time i tried something like this
you know what happened so we just either
stop ourselves
or we replan it and reframe it so it's
not exactly what we should do
and i think if we all lived in the
moment and went and if you look at
anybody who kind of went with their
instinct
in life and in our past that's the only
thing that has moved and
moved their lives ahead moved the world
ahead
you know everybody thought the world was
flat you know christopher columbus had
an impulse
let's just get a bunch of goofballs
we'll get on a boat let's sail off the
edge well if he didn't do that that's
not the norm
right because the thinking was you could
fall off the edge i
i don't think whether he believed it or
not he didn't know it
he just went for it you know so nike has
become my
analogy for how i live my life and
that's just do it
so i i i can't tell you how much of my
life i spend
you know terrified anxious but that's
that's debilitating
howie that's debilitating that's what
i'm saying depressed the anxiety all
those things part of the role
but there's it's just overwhelming it
can be debilitating
how do you make it less debilitating
when you go to a therapist
and you talk to your therapist what are
you talking to your therapist about if
you uh if you
because it feels like you know what
you're doing i would i would talk to him
like i'm talking to you right now i
would tell you that i'm having a really
hard time and i'm having a really hard
time during this pandemic
and uh i need uh coping skill
you know give me a coping skill and
whether that coping skill
is you know if you do goat yoga your
mind will go in a different direction
that's what i'm
i'm willing to do and whether it's being
needed a
need to be medicated or uh
for me aside from my medication and my
therapy and being surrounded by people
who care about me and support me and
love me
uh it's distraction and that those
distractions have to be like you know
double
doubly caffeinated distractions and
whether that's going on a
you know a spine tingling uh roller
coaster
or you know standing getting out there
in front of thousands of people that you
don't
know you know and trying to make them
laugh
those are coping skills in fact more
you know during the pandemic i didn't
realize how much
i did know that you know comedy changed
my life it's not anything that i
you know set out to do it wouldn't make
sense of anybody who comes from you know
i grew up in an apartment building in
toronto canada i don't know anybody that
was in show business i was never in a
school play
i just happened to go uh one night in
the mid 70s because i'm not a
dancer and i didn't like disco i went to
a comedy club
and just to see just because somebody
said we're going to a comedy club
tonight i went okay
and i went to a comedy club and uh
the guy it's jack-jack's in toronto and
mark breslin was the host
and he said does anybody want to get up
and you know it's monday night and at
midnight after the show
you know people can get up and try their
wares if this is something you aspire
to do or want to do and as a joke people
at my table went you should get up and
do it and i went okay
and it's nothing i aspired to do
there was no preparation you had no
material not not nothing on your mind
no and if you were you're probably
younger than me but if you go back to
youtube
and look at my first like how i started
out
see the joke was going to be you know i
i don't have a ged i was thrown out of
school i was
i wasn't diagnosed i'm 65 now so i grew
up in the 60s
and the 50s and you know my parents
didn't take me any place to
diagnose me with severe adhd and
ocd and depression and anxiety and i
couldn't i can't it's really hard for me
to sit still it's hard for me to listen
i was up and around so i got thrown out
of three different high schools
so when i found this when
my friend said you should get up i said
okay now
there was no thought process i didn't go
this is my opportunity to become a
comedian
this was uh maybe funny in the moment
because they were gonna go ladies and
gentlemen howie mandel
and i was gonna walk out i have a couple
of friends in the audience and i'm not
even a comedian
and i have no material and i just gotta
[ __ ] with them wouldn't that be great to
do
and that's even further than my thought
process went
so i go backstage the the
the next uh when i'm gonna go on and
uh mark president goes ladies and
gentlemen howie mandel and
i walk out isn't that funny i walked out
and and then i realized i'm standing
there like you know
i'm standing there on a stage there's a
microphone there
there's lights in my eye i'm blinded but
i could see the
the front row and now after they've
applauded they don't know me
they plotted my name i'm standing there
and you could see
strangers anticipating you know
right what you're doing right now like
the listeners why not
do something and then i got terrified
like i do on a roller coaster that it
just my adrenaline just bubbled up
inside me
and i realized oh [ __ ] this is
humiliating i've got nothing so i
started going oh okay
okay okay all right okay okay okay and
i'm panicking i'm trying to come up with
something and they started
giggling at my panic and i'm going okay
what and then he started laughing
and you got to watch an old youtube of
of me and then i would go what
what what that became your whole thing
in the beginning that well that was the
thing and they were laughing and
laughing
and laughing and i'm going i got look
what what all right oh please don't
laugh
okay all right all right i'm coming up
with things and that was just
real pure terror and and kind of trying
to
plan out loud i'm standing there with my
hands in my pocket i told you i have ocd
this is way before covid this is in the
70s and the 60s i put my hand in my
pocket
i have a my rubber glove because i
always carry rubber latex plus because
i don't want to touch [ __ ] you know i
use them to open doors and things like
that i bought them at the pharmacy
there and i just i go okay okay okay and
i took the
rubber glove and i put a rubber glove i
just pulled it over my head and i pulled
it over my nose i've never done that
before
i pulled over my nose and i'm breathing
and the fingers are going up and down
and i hear the audience even
just roaring so i start to inflate it
with my nose
and it flows and pops off my head and
the audience applied
without knowing i didn't know that you
want to leave them on a high note but i
just felt natural i went good night and
i ran off the stage
and mark brothers said can you come back
tomorrow and i went
what would i do because do the same
thing i could what was it
he goes just have fun i go i didn't i
don't think i had fun i think i was
terrified
but when i realized that was the first
time in my life
that you know i didn't have any friends
i really didn't i was uh you know kind
of a
i was miserable and i was alone and my
family was always supportive but i
didn't i did
so i went back and then that became my
uh conduit to
some sanity there was this place where i
could go each and every
night where there were a bunch of other
nerdy wells kind of like myself
who weren't uh at the at that moment
academically
you know that wasn't their thing because
this was i was still in school
you know so i thought this was no i
wasn't at this time i was
i got thrown out of school and i was
working
and and making a living but i didn't
care this was the most
fun where i could connect with people i
didn't even know
i felt that that laughter even in those
moments even if they were laughing at me
it was the first time i connected with
other human beings that didn't have the
same last name as me
you know and and just that connection
made me feel like
i wasn't alone you know this is a big
part of
what i feel so they were just laughing
at me so
i made it i just went i went on with
i'll be honest i had nothing and even if
you look at my young
comedian special i did a young comedian
special when i came out here
that next year i had met some comedians
who were uh
uh playing at yuck yucks i wasn't a
comedian but as i went every night there
was uh you know who uh
mike binder is a love binder good
buddies
yeah so binder i became friends with
binder and i became friends with this
other guy called uh
michael rap michael rapport who i i
don't think is around but they he lived
in l.a and wait
there's a michael rapport but not a
michael rap there's a michael rappaport
but there's also a mic i know michael
rappaport
i'm saying it was a michael rapport okay
he's like rap apart with
more rapport with more republicans all
right
so they said you guys should come out
and we made i made a vacation
with my wife we came out there and
binder got me on the
comedy store and i got seen by uh
it wasn't missy it's mitzi's best friend
i'm trying to remember what the lady's
name was
and she goes you gotta be a regular and
told missy about me missy made me a
regular but i wasn't
at the comedy store just for our
listeners at the comedy store mitzi
who ran the comedy store who just
recently passed away god rushed herself
but
her friend yeah and there was a producer
in the audience from a comedy game show
called make me laugh
george foster and he said he came up to
me said and this is my one
i've been in la for one day said kid you
want to do television
i would that that's what what are you
[ __ ] nuts this is like a
dream this is like yeah yeah he says
come to my office tomorrow
so my first time i was ever on a set
i've been in la
from 3000 miles away for you know 24
hours
i go to ktla where they do make me laugh
that's the first time i was ever on a
studio i've never even seen a studio
before it was amazing i was just blown
away
and he had me try to make his uh
secretary laugh and i had nothing okay
okay all right all right
puns and just silliness i mean he
thought it was funny he goes can you
tape a couple of days and i tape make me
laugh
i got on tv and i went back it was a
great story to tell
about my vacation but again not trying
to
pursue these are just things that happen
my whole career and my whole life
just happened just kind of just happens
and you could think
it's it's luck but what i've learned to
realize is somebody is 65 years old it's
not luck i'll tell you what the
with the i think we all have opportunity
in life
but the natural instinct well it's not
our instinct
our natural playbook is to figure out
why we shouldn't do it
it sounds stupid like if i had to think
about being a comedian
i mean what are the chances really what
are the changes right
even look what you're doing today if you
have to if you take yourself
back 35 years or 30 years and you said
this is what i
this is what i'm going to yeah you don't
even try it two years ago i would have
said what are you talking about someone
said you should do that you talk to
people
it'd be fun you're good with the what am
i doing and all of a sudden it's been to
over two years and yeah i never would
have thought i would i would do that but
so that's the thing i got to say like
even for you i'm a huge fan of your
acting i mean we have something in
common you know i played a bad guy
on uh lois and clark yes mr
mix of pithlick but uh but but but
anyway you're a great actor and
you know in reading you're knowing what
you're doing before i came on today you
said hey listen i had people over my
house i just started talking to them and
i realized
this is what i love to do right that the
thought process of coming out here and
getting into the business and saying you
know what i want to do i just want to
have friends over and people i'm
interested in and
talk to them and make that my my my job
for for the moment
it's it sounds ridiculous it doesn't
sound ridiculous on that
you never thought too much you never you
said yeah that sounds like
ineh if you would have started
dissecting these things like
oh if i do this but i i haven't done it
very long and all these other comedians
i'd have to at least go for a year
before i should really
before i'm a real comedian and i should
be doing then you're talking yourself
out of it already it's already over
and then you don't do it you know people
say to me on agt
you know what this is an old saying from
somebody before you know
i after i was there for three years i
said i'm not going to see any more i
think i've seen everything nothing's
going to blow me away
and every time i i say that somebody
shows up
and it blows me away and then i realized
that we are all creatures
who have this massive amount
of talent of uh productivity
of value and we
as a uh a species spend
a good portion of our strength locking
away that talent because of our fears
and our uh we think it's our
intelligence because we've thought it
over
you know instead of just doing it and
doing it means
making those mistakes you know but i
still i i don't have the answers i
i promise you i suffer each and every
not a day goes by when
when i don't feel the pain of whatever
it is that i
what do you wake up when you wake up in
the morning do you feel anxiety
uh my biggest anxiety is more when i go
to bed at night
so the the less active i am the more
i have an opportunity to go down the
wormhole so the quieter things are
the harder it is for me so if i
wake up in the morning and i as long as
if i have something to do
in that time and i will schedule
something
so that i don't i can't lie and if i
lied in bed it would be horror
sex at 10 30. and then i'll sleep you
just
whatever it is you plug it in there and
then you go to sleep you're on a
schedule
i gotta be yeah otherwise i just lie
there with nothing to do and the worst
thing that can happen and it happens now
more than not
because i'm older and i can't get
through an entire night without having a
piss
so because i get up in the middle of
night and piss
lying there after i piss it's not like i
don't have meetings to attend
i don't maybe i don't have a good idea
to write down
maybe so then it's just quiet time and
then my mind takes over
and my mind takes over and it ends in
the worst horror movie you could ever
imagine
you know having inside your own mind
inside of you is brought to you by helix
sleep helix sleep i'm telling you this
mattress is so freaking comfortable i
you know i told you all all this my
back's crap
i have a shitty back i'm constantly in
pain i can't get comfortable
for some reason this helix mattress
it just it works they have different
types of mattresses you can get
helix sleep has a quiz that takes two
minutes to complete and
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress
for you why would you buy a mattress for
someone else i don't know with helix
you're getting a mattress that you know
will be perfect for the way
you sleep everybody's unique and helix
knows that so they have several
different mattress models to choose from
they have soft they have medium i have
the medium
and firm mattresses mattresses great for
cooling you down if you sleep hot
and even a helix plus mattress for plus
size sleepers i took the helix quiz
on medium and this bed works perfectly
for me i am so comfortable and i have so
much less pain
than i normally do so thank you helix
it's this easy just go to helixsleep.com
slash inside h-e-l-i-x helix sleep.com
inside take their two-minute quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life and they have a
10-year warranty
and you get to try it out for 100 nights
100 nights risk free i don't know why
you're not doing this now helix is
offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com
inside sleep.com slash inside for up to
off and two free pillows get your helix
mattress now inside of you is brought to
you by
better help better help online therapy i
don't know what i would do without
therapy
i don't know what you're doing without
therapy um look the stigma is going away
people are going to therapy they're
getting help they're working on
themselves and better help is there for
you guys
i think it's a wonderful company and um
you know if you don't know what anxiety
is uh
talk to most people because they have it
i know i deal with it all the time and
um what is therapy
therapy is really whatever you guys want
it to be
for me it's talking about my problems
and unloading these problems on someone
who's objective and
um is not just someone i know because
you'll never tell
everything to someone you know it's
better to talk to someone who's a
professional who could really help you
get the tools to help with motivation
depression anxiety battling your temper
stress dealing with insecurity in
relationships or at work
whatever you need it's time to stop
being ashamed of normal human struggles
and start feeling better because you
deserve to be happy better help is a
customized online therapy that offers
video
phone uh even live chat sessions with
your therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to i
like to see my person i like to see them
reacting to me why you don't judge me
and they don't judge because they're
therapists and they're here to help us
uh it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy
and and by the way i know this it's a
fact
you spend so much more money by by going
into some place
better help is much much cheaper and
your therapist you'll
be communicating with in under 48 hours
join the millions of people
who are seeing what therapy is all about
what it's really all about
it may or may not be for you but it's
worth looking into because you are
your greatest asset this podcast is
sponsored by better help
and inside of you listeners get 10 off
their first month betterhelp.com
inside that's
dot betterhelp.com slash inside
you've been married 40 years which blows
me completely away because you know i i
41 next week
for happy anniversary how long did you
know before you got married
how long did you know each other i've
known her
uh probably close to
uh 55 years i knew her probably uh
we grew up in the same area i mean we
didn't we haven't been
uh together for 55 years understandable
56 years
i dated her friends she dated my friends
i
uh but i always liked her she didn't
like me
so i pursued and i won
and and she you always had these ocd
things and the adhd and all these things
that you
were they okay so are they obvious yeah
were they obvious
to her but you see in my era you know
uh and i think most people's era like
today i
i i love that you do the show and that
you're as open as you
are about issues and real people and
because i i truly believe you know we're
moving in the right direction but we're
not even close to the right direction
of there being a stigma involved with
mental health
so she knew about it but you wouldn't
call them that it was just like i was a
a germ a germ freak you know he doesn't
want to touch anything that's dirty he
doesn't want to get sick
he uh he won't share a drink he won't
you know it's just even my parents i was
quirky
and that's who i was but quirky was as
far as you would go
rather than saying he has a mental
health problem and even today you know
when we sit in a
corporate office someplace in middle
america you know you go oh
i hurt my back everybody will give you a
card to their chiropractor
or if you said i got to go out this
afternoon and i'm getting a wisdom tooth
old i just got so much pain i can't work
nobody has a problem or they say you
should go to my dentist but god forbid
in the middle of the day when you work
at a bank you can go listen i i don't
know what's going on but i just can't
function
i am so [ __ ] depressed and i just
need to see somebody so i'm going to
take the afternoon off
i don't think that's the same kind of
acceptance that you get for a dental
uh you know i always say we need to make
it part of our curriculum now where we
take care of our
mental health the way we take care of
our dental health yeah i'm getting a new
canal
yeah i 100 agree with you there i mean
that that's
to me the more we talk about it you know
i had a guy who had an anxiety attack on
the podcast this guy stephen amellas
actor
and i said you want me to you want me to
just get rid of it
he goes let me listen to it and you can
hear him going hey
hey rosie i think i'm having an anxiety
attack here
and this guy's he's he plays the arrow
he's a he's a huge comic book guy you
know
and i listen to it he goes no i think
it's important for people to hear it and
i just
admired that so much and it is i mean
especially when you're growing up
you can it just seems especially in
canada everybody's kind of tough hockey
player
i always imagine that like everybody
just the last thing you want to do
everybody's more private in canada you
know i don't think that everybody
more private i don't know that they're
more private i just think that we are
you know and i i haven't really noticed
the difference i i feel
blessed that i you know i happened into
this
industry and i happened into something
where look
in the course of a day i'm on your show
even talking about it besides this
maybe being you know a tidbit of
information i'll tell you who's getting
the most out of this and
hopefully you guys get something out of
it but i'm getting the most out of it
the ability to be
able to be open and have a forum where
you could talk about it
and like you know
the gentleman had the panic attack on
your show you know that's how
i i don't know i read i wrote my
autobiography a few years back
yeah you know that's what happened to me
i had a panic attack on howard stern's
show
and uh he was they were [ __ ] around
in the room there was somebody who had
done i think it was uh
anyway some guy pulled his dick out he
was playing with his dick on the show
and he was there and then he left and i
saw that he touched the door
so when i finished my uh segment with
howard i was about to leave
and i was wearing like short sleeves and
and i said can somebody grab the door i
don't want to touch the [ __ ] door
that guy had his dick all over the door
and they go no just open the door i go
i'm a germaphobe i don't want to touch
the door they go i touched the door they
were having
fun with me and i said no and i went to
grab a tissue to grab the door and they
knocked the
tissue away from me and then i was
trying to pull out my shirt tail and
they were
holding me from that and that's i
started to have a
i never really talked openly about it
before and i started to have a
panic attack and i and i was going and
and a panic attack feels for those who
have never had one like i'm having a
heart attack i can't breathe and i
couldn't
function and i was getting dizzy and i
said howard howard howard you got to get
me out of here i'm going to end up in
the hospital i go to a
psychiatrist i have something called
obsessive compulsive disorder i'm on
medication please you got to help me now
i'm gonna pass out i'm gonna pass out
gotta open the door for me gotta open
the door
so he went okay okay and he opened the
door and i went out in the hall and i
was sure that we were
in a commercial when i was leaving you
know he had finished with me
and i was sure we were in a commercial
but i heard as soon as i walked out the
other door
they were still they go whoa whoa what
the [ __ ] was that what happened to howie
and i realized
we were on the air and that went out
nationally and you have to realize for
me
that was the very first time that i had
ever
mentioned publicly besides to besides to
my own
family my maybe closest friends and my
uh therapist and psychiatrist what my
issue was
and i was devastated when i heard it
coming through the speakers
i i went [ __ ] and my first thought was
this is the end this is the absolute end
number one my family's going to hear
this
and anybody they know you know i have
three children and my wife is in la
now it's on the air that you know i have
mental health issues
that i'm gonna be with number one
they're gonna be ridiculed at school
your dad's a mental case he has mental
health issues this is where my mind
number two i'm never going to be able to
get a job again any job
you know they take insurance when i say
that i have mental health issues and i'm
medicated and i need to see a
psychiatrist
who's going to want to hire me and
number three i'm just so humiliated and
depressed
this is the end and i'm standing there
and i get in the elevator manhattan and
i'm going down the
the elevator and i think this is the end
i i don't even know how to face my own
children i'm just going to run into
traffic i don't know what to do
and i got down to the lobby and i'm
looking through the lobby manhattan
the most teeming city in the world with
thousands of people out on the streets
and and the traffic and i go through the
automatic doors and doors open i'm
standing there on the sidewalk and i'm
just
you know getting up the wherewithal to
take my leap
into traffic and as it
was some guy comes up into my periphery
i couldn't make eye contact i didn't i
didn't want to i was just looking down
and he goes are you howie mandel and i
went yeah
he goes i just heard you on stern and i
could physically feel
my heart drop into my stomach you know
and i went oh my god
you know i'm just gonna run one and i
went two
and and he whispered in my ear i could
feel the air of his breath on my ear
and he went me too and this is before me
too meant what it means now and i went
i didn't know it what does that mean me
too he goes no i suffer
too i'm very depressed and i'm very
anxious and i have
it was so thank you for you know
doing that publicly like i didn't do it
on purpose but he goes
it made me feel like i'm not alone and i
said well you just and i turned to him
you just
you just opened up a little door for me
i you know the the one
overwhelming in our darkest moments if
there was
one description that you could give to
anybody in their darkest moments
is is that they feel alone they feel so
like look what's happening to me look at
this dark hole i'm going down
look at what's happened it's not you're
not there is no company in that there is
no joy
in having other people around but now i
had this other person around and he made
me feel good and i didn't run into
traffic and i'm here today
but after that this was before email and
before the internet
i started getting every week i started
getting a ton and ton of
a ton tons of uh letters and mail going
thank you
thank you and you had no idea i wasn't
helping them but every time i got these
letters
it helped me i go oh my god it's how
nice is this
to be able to know that you're not alone
it's like the buddy system in swimming
you know
it could be cold it could be choppy but
there's other people there and if you
need help just
reach out your arm they're there and
what uh
what uh a journey from that moment on
the sidewalk in manhattan
to sitting here and talking to you today
is is night and day that's the yin and
the yang
and what needs to happen for absolutely
everyone
i i honestly that got me i was i got a
little emotional i
went through a lot of what you just went
through or went through that day like i
almost felt like
i felt the anxiety of you going down the
elevator i felt like the complete
it's almost like the blood you could
feel it coming out of you like draining
down
physical and you just feel like you're
like this is the end when you realize
you wish you could be on the outside
going dude you're alive this is not the
end this is
but in your mind the body and everything
you feel like
i am i want i don't want to be here
right now i
i'm done i'm done it's like it and then
you go outside and i i i it was so
visual and you're right i mean i didn't
know i'll be honest with you i've said
this before but i
i didn't i thought i was doing this
podcast because oh i could talk to
people and maybe you all get sponsors
and people will listen and i'll make
some money
that's what i [ __ ] thought i didn't
know that all of a sudden
me being vulnerable and me starting to
open up to all these people and really
you you hit the nail on the head when
you said you're doing it for you
i i start the more i was open and real
the better i felt and the more people it
would attract more people and
i'd run into folks overseas at
conventions or whatever
and they'd say they come up to me crying
like i was honestly like i was a
like i had all the answers which i don't
i'm just somebody who talks about
problems and things in real life stuff
and get great guests like you who open
up and talk about something that might
help them and
and i realized then that's purpose for
me because i didn't know what you know
at least it's a little purpose because
i'm always searching for more purpose in
my life but
to help people you know i think that's
why each of us is put here i think
that you know if there is a purpose it's
connecting
you know and whether you connect every
every one of us
looks for a way to connect and whether
it's
you know why do you want to go out and
make a lot of money
because you know when somebody's uh
really into that
that's their way of they believe that
that's their connection if i become in
their mind successful because
i'm rich or i own this company that's
their connection to the world
everybody's gonna look to me everybody's
gonna come to me to buy this thing
we are all regardless of what you do in
life you're an entertainer
everybody's going to watch me
everybody's going to listen to me
if you're a model everybody's going to
look at me everybody's going to buy my
doesn't matter what you do in life we're
all doing it to find
some way into this into the world
some way that they want the world to
look at them they want to be connected
because when with mental health mental
health
is the the the super disconnector
you know that disconnects you from
everything that's going on everything
that's in
everybody everybody else's you know um
periphery and it just sends you into
your own little
tunnel that's what mental health is so
we need to connect you know i do this
campaign in canada for
bell media and it's called bell let's
talk and
we believe that the first step to um
mental health is just talking and
whether i'm talking to you
on a podcast or talking to my therapist
or talking to my wife or talking to a
friend and not
being recorded anywhere that's the key
and we don't
and we don't share for most people you
know
it's very funny because they always say
like oh look at your
very show business to me the bigger show
is the people that aren't in the
business
see i think that show business
creativity
in it has given us the ability to peel
away
everything and kind of be who we are or
or we want to be whereas when you're in
um regular life
you know just because somebody's a
banker you know and they have to wear a
suit and a tie every day
you know they're creating that's the
bigger show because those are the people
that you you know
my wife now that we're in lockdown we're
watching id
you know and he was a good member of
society and then he wiped out the whole
family
next door i feel like more people
outside of this business
are putting on shows than we put on
because they're the ones that have to
they have the dress codes of where they
work they're being told they're acting a
certain way because that's what they
have to do at their job
that's the show you don't know what's
going on inside their real minds they're
putting on a show whereas
more people in our business just because
we're given the license to
could be honest you know and can in in
the name of creativity maybe be our real
selves
wow that's pretty damn profound let me
ask you this do you think
you being medicated and first of all was
it hard to find the right medication to
help you and b did it save your life or
do you think you would have gone on
or it was no it saved my life but that
being said
um it's always uh uh you know uh
i happen to be that's why i don't know
that i'm a good spokesperson for
anything
you know i happen to have one of my
issues is something that is diagnosable
and treatable and is a chemical you know
people always say i'm a little ocd you
can't be a little ocd
ocd when you actually have ocd like
other people think they're a little like
oh it drives me crazy when somebody
wants to shake your hand or i don't like
when something's messy
well me too but the point is that if
somebody shakes my hand and i'm
triggered and i
if i'm triggered and i have to wash my
hand there are times where i
won't stop washing my hand for six hours
you know until it's almost bleeding six
hours six hours
i've got i have not in years right but
i'm saying like i just
i'll go just like you know if you shook
somebody's hand and it was a little
moist and it was icky you'd go off [ __ ]
what was on his hand
and you go wash your hands so i go wash
my hands not all the time i'm saying
when
my right issue is triggered are
triggered i'll go wash my hands
i just don't shake hands i can shake
hands i just don't shake hands now
because
i don't want to be triggered you know
and then i go back and i go you know
what i don't think i got it all
and then i go back and watch i'll give
you i'll give you an exam another
example that's kind of normal that
people will understand but
i've talked about this i've i've been
leaving to go on an appointment for a
meeting
and then i don't think i locked the door
just like somebody thinks they left the
oven on or they don't think they lock
the door
so i go back and i check the door and
then i get back in the car and i go you
know what
i don't know if i shook it enough so i
get back out and i shake it again
these are normal thoughts these are
normal and maybe even a little obsessive
and i go you know what i don't think i
really should get enough and i get back
out again
and then i'm sitting there and i have an
urge to go check one more time and i go
this is [ __ ] i know
intellectually it's crazy i did it but
i'm forced to
obsessive and compulsive i have to check
it again so i
go to the door again and the fourth time
i smash it with my
knuckles so that i know that my thought
process is if i feel the
the pain the throbbing pain in my neck
almost broke my knuckle
if i feel the throbbing pain then i'll
know i have checked it and i won't go
back
and and i do that and then i sit in the
car and i go you know what it's
throbbing
but i bet i knocked it open i bet i
knocked it open i better go down
yeah and then but these are uh
that's ocd that's not a little ocd
that's ocd
right right and it stopped my life and i
missed the appointment and it stopped my
life it's
i worry about germs and then wash my
hands till my hand is scalded and
bleeding that's ocd
but i forgot what the question was well
medications
you said medication saved your life for
that yes so i
i was going down the wormhole my wife
said i can't take this anymore we have
to
the kids can't take this anymore i went
and got uh
medicated got the wrong uh with a
chemical body
chemicals it didn't work in fact threw
me
even deeper i had to change medication
even now
you know right now i'm on a really good
dosage and medication but as i get
older your body chemistry changes i may
you know it ain't over
until it's over i could slip down the
slide again i always just have to be
aware and maintain
and maybe i'll have to up my dose maybe
i'll have to change my medication
it isn't done by the same token i'm also
finding tools throughout my life
that will help me you know for me
running is huge
you know i need to run i run every day i
just run
on a treadmill and i don't listen to
music and i don't watch tv
i just run and hear my feet smashing on
the floor
i feel my breath and my heartbeat and
for some reason maybe that's like
meditation that takes me
out of the moment wow well i'm glad you
talked about that openly i mean that's
i think that's tough for you but i think
a lot of people are best
and i think that you know for me as even
not being diagnosed this is what i'm a
proponent of there isn't anybody alive
that isn't at one point in their life
going to be needing a coping skill
and that is you know whether you you're
devastated because a relationship broke
up
whether and you end up self-medicating
and
drinking and whatever you're doing to
yourself that you're gonna
eventually need help uh whether even
becoming a parent you know i have three
kids there's no that's a lot of
responsibility that's a lot of weight
you know or being told that somebody you
love or yourself
is uh incredibly ill be getting a cancer
diagnosis
like nobody goes it's not part of the
curriculum to go to say how do i
mentally
help this you know and i go speak on
capitol hill as far as
insurance companies wanting to i want
them to parody
the same kind of support it's really
easy to get your insurance company to
take care of a fractured femur
on your leg but if you say i just can't
function because my wife i caught my
wife
cheating you can't you can't get
funded to go sit at a therapist's office
right and that could be
as if not more debilitating than a
cracked femur
yeah right same token even if you are
legitimately
you know you get if two people have the
same surgery but
one of them is not that mentally fit
it is tried and proven that the healing
process doesn't go as well
mind over matter is real it's not just
the same
inside of you is brought to you by geico
michael do you own your home i own my
home ryan do you own your home i rent my
home
and what's the hardest part about life
besides paying rent i mean there's a lot
of things i mean but it's a big one but
paying rent is up there paying your
mortgage paying your rent is tough
and and you know it's it's a pain in the
ass
well it's a pain in the ass it is it's a
pain that not only is the pain in the
ass but when you have to pay all these
other people
you pay your auto you pay your home you
pay our time is valuable
so geico's there guys and what do they
call they're called
bundling policies that's correct
bundling policies
geico makes it easy to bundle your
homeowners or renters insurance along
with your auto policy uh we all we have
too much
uh too much to do in our lives and it's
easy to go to geico.com
everybody's doing it you just get a
quote you see how much you could save
it's geico
easy geico geico.com
visit geico.com today that's geico.com
ryan it's so easy rosenbomb can do it
today's program is brought to you by
athletic greens
i love this stuff ryan i've told you
over and over guys listen to this
you know you wake up in the morning some
people don't eat
some people make a really unhealthy
breakfast
um they're not getting the vitamins
they're not getting the nutrients
what if i told you in one glass pout put
some powder in a glass of water mix it
and you're gonna get
so many healthy things down your face i
would say that's insane are you sure
ryan one glass of this athletic greens
has more 75 vitamins minerals and whole
foods sourced ingredients
including multivitamin multi-mineral
probiotic green superfood blend and more
that all work together to fill the
nutritional gaps in your diet they
increase your energy
i'm telling you as a fact this is it's
so easy
i just take a packet i dump it in water
and it tastes delicious ryan you can
attest to that i can yeah
get more focus uh it aids with digestion
supports a healthy immune system all
without the need to take multiple
products and vi
i just can't take any more pills i don't
want to do it
athletic greens is there for you i use
it i think you should too
and right now athletic greens is
doubling down on supporting your immune
system during the coming months they're
offering
our audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin d
and five travel packs with your first
purchase if you visit
the link today you'll basically never
have to buy vitamin d again
never have to buy vitamin d look whether
you're looking for peak performance
or better health covering your bases
with athletic greens makes investing in
your energy immunity and gut health each
day simple tasting efficient
and here's what you do folks all you
have to do is go to athleticgreens.com
y-o-u and join health experts athletes
and health-conscious go-getters around
the world who make a daily commitment to
their health
every single day again visit
athleticgreens.com
y-o-u and get your free year supply of
vitamin d and
five free travel packs today that's
athletic greens.com
y-o-u i i read a couple of things that
kind of
pissed me off because i felt like it was
harassment i felt like
you whipped your head around no i mean
it was they violated you like
i read an article where marshall falk
like uh yeah and i remember that and
let me tell you yes the truth is
yes and he got hit for that a little bit
on on social media
but the truth is i kind of have this
understanding you have to realize
i'm for the most part uh a lot of people
know me as a comedian
so and i've made it you're approachable
well and not only that i've i i've
talked about it within the context of
comedy
you know made it light not with that
particular incident you're talking about
was on deal or no deal
and it became kind of a funny thing
because people were excited there
and they wanted to hug me and like you
know what happened
what happened exactly oh he said you
know he goes he's a germaphobic shake
their hand i'm gonna shake their hand
and he was chasing me around the set and
he grabbed my hand and he shook my hand
and the truth is i didn't get triggered
that particular day but people are right
they're going listen
i and it's the people that are suffering
the same thing as me
when they understand it's it's real and
even though i make joke and
make jokes about it like it's you know
what is real and what's not real is he
is he making jokes about being a
germaphobe who doesn't like
jokes and is he exaggerating it it's
kind of funny to play that
joke on me you know what i mean like
it's chasing murray langston around the
office
to pull the bag over his head but it's
not funny
but it's not funny if you you're
triggered if i would have been triggered
it probably would have ended badly but i
wasn't triggered but i kind of
understand
humanity and i understand people don't
know about it
we're talking about this in america
you're
right now today and people who are
listening to this podcast
it's a much different world but you know
and and people are taking mental health
really seriously and mental health has
become
part of our pop culture you know people
are open about drinking people are
opening you know
britney spears all over the the news
right now and there's
much more of a compassionate lilt to it
than there was the first time that she
was in the news
with all with all that so it was a
different time yeah
yeah that is kind of a
what that did for me rather than feeling
anything
uh negative about marshall i just
realized that's the world
the world doesn't understand the world
if i'm not bleeding
and i'm not unconscious then they don't
understand suffering
and even on this podcast i don't know if
people watch this zoom call
but you know i'm sitting i'm sitting in
a house i'm smiling
i have a an amazing career i feel like
one of the luckiest people in the world
and uh
what kind of [ __ ] suffering is that
you know everybody has their own you
can't feel my pain
do you ever get mad on america's uh i
almost said america's most wanted
on america's most wanted uh america's
gotta get it no america's got talent do
you
ever get mad at the other guys like
really going what the [ __ ] are they
seeing
this is terrible how are they loving
this does that happen between
no i'll tell you because this is the
sick way when i first i i tell the story
a lot but when i
when i first like really popped on the
scene and i was doing sane elsewhere and
i was doing
all that this is the way you know and i
was getting
when i blew up i i became the uh
uh i was the butt of a lot of jokes you
know before there was
uh i'm not gonna name the other comics
who have become the butts of jokes
because i don't think there needs to be
that but because i was silly
and because i had props there was i was
very
i can't tell you how many times i was
mentioned in letterman's top 10 list
you know and then it was like the last
thing no we'll let him we'll take him to
a howie mandel show
you know it was was the was the funny
thing but what i realized is
i went on sale at one time uh radio city
music hall i did radio city music call
and i put it up on sale and it sold out
in like an hour two hours we put a
second show up on
sale and that sold out in a couple hours
and you know there's in the 80s
and we went to uh new york and i was i
did the first show
and i'm up in the dressing room and
we're looking down onto 7th avenue
and on 7th avenue you know 7 000 people
are coming out
of radio city music hall as 7 000 people
for the next show
are coming in so there's 15 000 people
in the center manhattan
and you could see the the cops had put
stanchions up
and and they were directing traffic and
there was a jam and
my wife is sitting there looking out the
window and i'm looking out the window at
the crowd and she goes
this is all for you this is like what
are you thinking and i said you really
want to know what i'm thinking
and and she said yeah and i said and
this is the first time i came
i said there's 14 15 000 people down
there
we are in i think at the time
at a city of what 10 million how many
are in new york i you ask in the world i
think it's like at least 10 million
just in the manhattan so that means that
000 don't give a [ __ ] that i'm here
right in their city
there's always but that kind of made me
realize
that as much as you feel that you're
loved or you've hit or you're doing it
right
there's everybody's an individual and
there's going to be more people that
don't like it so do i get
mad that they like something no am i i'm
fascinated now by what somebody else
likes that i don't
and that draws me more and i can't tell
you how many times
um i watch because i'm trying to
distract myself i'm either on youtube
or television 24 7 i keep things on
there's always things on the tv's on all
night or whatever
i'll turn it to the iranian station and
watch some obscure
show not in english that i can try to
kind of figure out what's going on and
why people besides
understanding the language would even
tune into this [ __ ] like why did they
even make this so i'm fascinated by what
draws
or what what is that magnet to people
even me
you know now when i tell you how i
started my career i started my career
with nothing nothing and if you told me
that one day against your will
they're gonna pull you on stage and
you're just gonna get scared
shitless and not be able to come up with
nothing and that's gonna buy your first
house
it would make no sense and what i
realized is and
i don't know that i can articulate what
it is that drew those people to me
but i can tell you that that feeling
that okay what what which i don't do
anymore was
really authentic maybe we all feel like
fish out of water who are struggling to
maybe say the right thing in the moment
who are struggling to not look like an
idiot who are struggling to just come up
with something and move ahead
maybe it's just that you know
that relatability that you know is not
something that i can't express in words
i don't know what it is
but what i did learn is to be true to
myself
and even if something is silly and it's
not informative you know
i was not a respected comedian ever you
know
i was the guy that had the glove on my
head i was the guy that carried a
handbag in the you know and then you had
other comedians that had
you know that did political yeah but
respect you see wait a minute
respected by whom like if you're
thinking your peers oh they don't
respect me because i'm
but but only only i what i did garner
from day one is i garnered
a a small slice of an audience which
i've
maintained or or brought together from
various things but
i can't look to those other yeah my
peers didn't
but it used to it used to kill me being
the brunt of the joke it used to kill me
you know being the you know i'm not
my persona is that of being
really silly and an idiot and and
likeable
i put that out there and that is part of
me that is real
i am a silly idiot i do like awkward
moments
i love silliness i like it sometimes
because it's just stupid
you know because it's stupid that's what
i like but then again there's kind of a
uh a veil of does he know it's stupid or
is it just stupid or is it just corny or
is he doing it because it's corny
it's like uh when steve martin used to
put the arrow on his head and
i'm a wild and crazy guy right well is
he does he
well he did it as an accent so you knew
that steve martin didn't really think
that that was a brilliant
but it is a brilliant observation of the
guy that's trying to be the party guy
he's trying to be funny in the center of
attention at a party
i love that kind of humor but you gotta
my favorite kind of thing is when the
and my family knows this i don't really
like
i don't need the laughter i like uh um a
response
and whether that response when i walk my
wife is constantly saying not
recently not in the last year but who's
the [ __ ] joke on
who's to joke on they just you walk out
of that store and they think you're the
biggest [ __ ] idiot in the world
and and the joke i kind of like that
i i like when they don't know that i'm
kidding and they just think that i'm an
idiot
i love it i don't know why i like that
but i love that hey this is [ __ ] talking
with howie
rozzy can you still do the voice of
bobby from bobby's world i'm guessing
yes but you won't so
we can move on i will i could do it
i can do it that that voice is a voice
that i
got i talked about in my act i was
choking on a piece of cake and at
school and at a birthday party and
everybody was laughing at me and i
i used to do that from the back of the
room but it's funny it became the voice
from bobby's world but it was also
you know i did uh the uh muppet babies
i was skeeter on the muppet [ __ ] and
you were gizmo in gremlins
same voice believable you probably made
so much money off just doing that video
i did really good
and right now for you they brought him
back he's got a mountain dew
uh commercial so i did it i did it again
but i did that but i did other voices
too i did
animal and bunsen honeydew jesus
i remember the bobby that i remember
when i was a kid just going
i can't do it but i was like my name is
bobby and sometimes people say hey bobby
and i stay away from bobby what
yeah i can do it he says what are you
doing
mommy put you on the potty every time
my mommy puts me on the potty i cry
why do you cry because it's my party and
i'll cry if i want to
that didn't i was that in tune that was
that came off kind of weird i just
remember it's my body
quoted that that was quotable it was fun
it was like memorable
i love it lisa h one of my favorite
movies he has been in his walk like a
man
any fun memories from working on that
movie all around great cast
it was an amazing cast no fun memories
as much as
a lot of pain still in my lower back and
uh these aren't real teeth in front of
me because christopher lloyd who played
my brother in it
um there was a thing for those that
don't know i was raised by a pack of
wolves and i did this whole movie on all
fours and i was most of the movie on all
fours and i had a
bite down on this bone and then he rips
the bone out of my mouth he was supposed
to rip it out on the count of three and
he went one
two and ripped and you could see in the
in the film
there's a piece of white it looks like
there's a piece of meat flying but it's
actually my tooth
my tooth flew out of my head live and i
got up they yelled cut
and i got up and i didn't real didn't
realize what had happened i felt this
huge vibration
in my face but the tooth broke but the
nerve stayed in my
in my mouth nerve was hanging down like
a hair
and i smiled and the wind hit it i never
had i know what childbirth is like now
i think oh
i can imagine you going would you do
that for he's like well
i thought you'd get a better reaction if
i pulled it out on two
that's amazing i got a really good
impression i don't even do that one
but then you do that how do you do that
one and then say you don't do that well
i do it just to make it
make the joke and then i uh all right
you know what i do
i know you do a lot you do a good
christopher walken yeah but everybody
does walking now
you know what do you do that no one does
i think i have the best rodney
dangerfield for sure i love rodney
did you know rodney i never and i and i
god i want i mean he's one of my
favorites of all time i wish i knew i
know you know
i'm the man i got to hang with him i got
to it was
amazing do rodney i love rod uh my wife
told me to take out the trash
i said you cooked it you take it out all
right i love it i love it i
every time that he was on the johnny
carson show
i mean that was i set my whole day
around waiting for him to do
he was great with you nonstop by the way
if you had
i know you're going to say johnny
carson's your favorite of all time right
let's just get through it no who's your
favorite of all time
i'd like you know letterman made me
laugh more than johnny
you know johnny from my from my era
johnny was the
the king maker you know that's going on
the johnny carson show
was the litmus test for being considered
a comedian you know
when i was coming up i had done you know
mike douglas and merv griffin and john
davidson and
all the shows that were out there norm
crosby's comedy shop but i hadn't done
the tonight show
and and people would say who didn't know
me in the street would go what do you do
and i'd say i'm a comedian
and anybody who was who was out of the
business would go well have you been on
johnny carson like this was that
that was the litmus test if you hadn't
been on johnny carson you weren't
considered a professional but i ended up
doing it
22 times um 22
times ladies and gentlemen johnny and oh
just
i'd love for just saying you're and he
had you sit down with him
yeah i'll tell you you want to know that
story about getting on johnny yeah that
was hard
so getting on johnny was the thing that
was going to you know
put your career in stone and uh there
was a guy by the name of jim mccauley
who was the
he was the casting guy he was the guy
that booked the comics and i always had
him come out to the comedy store
and not only did i not get on he told me
howie
you're never gonna get on the the thing
you do the silliness
you know we like monologists the
silliness and the toys and everything
you do
is so anti-johnny it's you're never
gonna get on i was devastated
and then uh joan rivers started hosting
the tonight show she was filling in
right for john i remember that and when
she was filling in for
johnny the ratings were through the roof
she was a big star so much so but this
is before that so much so that
fox ended up hiring her and you know
when fox became a network
the joan rivers show was became their
late night
saddle they took her because it was so
big and she ended up being an enemy of
johnny's so she would come she lived in
new york but she would come to la
when she was filling in for johnny and
she would work as everyone did they
would work out their set
at the comedy store so and i was close
with mitzi at the time
and uh in i think was in 1985
she was uh on a certain week there she
was uh
going to fill in for johnny and she was
going to come in every night and doing
like a nine o'clock spot at the comedy
store to just
go over her monologue for the next day
so
um i asked um mitzi
if she could book me everybody did five
minute segments
five minute sets if you could book me at
8 55
right before joan comes on maybe joan
will see me
and want me to be on it won't be like
being on johnny carson but
i'll be on the tonight show so she did
so
that thursday it was i wake up in the
morning
with 104 fever i'm like [ __ ] dying
and this is the one time i'm gonna joan
rivers i'm supposed to play that night
i'm sitting there and i'm shivering and
and i go i'm not gonna have this
opportunity again i'm not gonna be able
to call mitzy
next week and say put me on at 9 55
again let's do it i just
i got to take this opportunity so i got
into the car and i'm
shivering and i'm driving through laurel
canyon and i think i'm gonna
crash the car i'm so dizzy anybody who's
had a high fever just knows you're
you're like rubber i don't know how i
was even
sitting in an upright position i get to
the
comedy store i'm sitting there and i
don't know how i'm going to get on
it comes to be 9 55. joan rivers comes
into the room
i'm going on once and she's going on
right after me they go ladies and
gentlemen howie mandel
and i get on and i think that performers
will understand but there's an
adrenaline that just came over me i got
an adrenaline for
for for the first moment in the last 18
hours
i didn't feel sick right and i just
started popping off whatever i was doing
in my act and they were roaring
and they were screaming and i went good
night
and the crowd went nuts for me and then
i go ladies and gentlemen
joan rivers and joan rivers you know at
the comedy store i walk
off the stage and she's passing me in
the aisle as she's coming on the stage
we
introduced her and i introduced her and
she stopped right in the in the
uh she goes you are so [ __ ] funny and
i went thank you thank you and then she
has to continue she goes on stage
she walks on the stage the crowd is like
beside themselves they're screaming and
yelling and and as and i was like my
heart was beating and that was great she
said i was wonderful
and i'm waiting at the back and she's
going on
and on and on and she's killing and it's
10 minutes and it's 15 minutes it's 20
minutes
and my adrenaline is kind of flowed out
of me and now the fever is coming back
and i'm sliding down the wall
and i'm in the room so i make my way to
the front steps
to go out towards sunset and i can't
even walk down the steps and i'm sitting
on the steps against the wall leaning
there
in a cold sweat i'm just sick i'm
shivering and i'm just waiting i just
want to make eye contact with her
one time and she spent like 20 minutes
25 minutes on stage when she got off
mitzi's talking to her every comics
talking to her and i stood there for
about an hour
and then she comes out that you know
it's the front stairway that goes out in
sunset boulevard and i'm lying on the
steps
and she looks down at me and she goes oh
you're still here you're you're funny
and i go thank you she goes have you
ever been on the tonight show
i go it's my birthday next week and she
said call billy samus
who was her manager at the time he's a
funny guy if you saw her
uh he disappeared from her if you saw
her did you ever watch her
documentary yeah yep brilliant i
remember he he's the guy that
disappeared yeah in the middle of it
but she said call him and gave me his
number and i phoned him in the morning
and she said she wants you on this week
i went [ __ ] this is amazing oh my god
that's celestine prophecy celestine
prophecy [ __ ] right there
right so listen to this story so anyway
i so i go on
it's just panel because my my stuff is
it's still like stand up but i
you know i set up the questions like
rodney dangerfield did and i would go
into these bits
for the life of me i can't remember what
i did with her but it was really good
that morning after the show and and it
was so so realistic you know you'd hear
the music you go ladies and gentlemen
i was on the set and you hear doc
severance
and every kid you know that music that
theme song
was in everybody's house you know i
think like 30 million people 20 million
people were watching a night
so that morning i get a call from jim
mccauley
who says johnny watched you last night
with joan
he loved it is there any way you can
come back and do it with him next week
i went are you [ __ ] kid are you
kidding me
so i i was so excited i love this so i
got up and did it and this is still on
youtube
and i said listen he's he's beat into my
head
that my [ __ ] is not what johnny likes
i'm so afraid that my [ __ ] is not what
johnny likes but you know what
if i do it once and i'm never asked back
again
i could always say i did the tonight
show and i can always answer everybody
in the street
and that is the litmus test and i will
be a real comedian
so i go on the first time with johnny
and i'm sitting there and i do this
stuff that you know
jim mccauley was so hands-on with the
this is this tell me your last line of
that when is johnny going to come in
with the next question
unlike we did on this podcast there was
an incredible amount of plan
and then i figured you know what [ __ ] it
i'm just gonna take a shot when do you
get this opportunity
so i did this bit that i didn't tell
jim mccauley about it's not even that
funny but it was me
i want to be true to myself and i take
out you know i brought this
huge prop bag on this handbag shaped in
a hand and i take out these
these uh 3d glasses you know like they
gave you in movie theaters every time in
the 80s
paper one's red one's blue you know
those yeah and i say to johnny i
say johnny you like 3d he goes yeah i
love the 3d movies i go you got to try
this
put these on and johnny puts on these 3d
glasses and i'm sitting in the guest
seat you know
our heads are what uh two and a half
feet from each other
you know and i said tell me if this
works for you and i reach into the bag
and i take out the stuffed animal
and and in my mind i'm thinking this
could go horribly wrong
at best and i take it and i whip it
right at his face
and smash him in the face with this
stuffed animal
and then i just and it was like quiet it
took like a second for
i just threw [ __ ] in johnny's face
without a plan and it could feel like
behind me because the producer's just
off camera and everybody's going
[ __ ] like we didn't tell him this was
going to happen and i
and i said doesn't it look like it's
coming right at you
it took a second he just broke up
laughing and went back in the seat and
was kicking and everything just loving
it and everybody blew up and that was
the
he had me back every two weeks for 22
weeks
until i got unbelievable that's how you
got banned from the show
yeah why didn't you i got banned i'll
tell you what that was so i did it 22
times
and then they called me one time i was
there
they loved me as a guest and they knew
that they could call me anytime
anybody fell out same day and they would
they would get it done
i would show up and and do a spot um
so they uh they called me one time
and i was uh in the middle of doing a
movie i was doing
a fine mess with ted danson and we were
at this
laird studios in culver city and i get a
call and i'll never forget this this was
the time that
um the the person that was booked was
sammy davis jr
and sammy davis jr that afternoon got
diagnosed with throat cancer and had to
cancel
that's when he found out he had so they
called me at 2 30 in the afternoon jim
calls me and says hey listen sami
you'll be the lead guest sammy had to
leave
you got to come in and i go jim i i'm
always there for you buddy
but i got nothing i got nothing i can't
he goes you got to do it i don't know
who else to probably made a couple of
else other calls nobody you're the only
one who answered you got it
i go jim for you and for johnny i'll
be there but here's what i i got to ask
of you
i don't have any time i can't sit down
i'm in the middle of a movie right now
and i know i'm rapping at
uh three o'clock so i'll come from right
here i'll come
to the studio and shoot but i got i
don't have any material i'll think of
something
but i can't think of things tell you the
things have you go over the set
change things i don't have any time for
that so can you just trust me
he goes i i there's nothing else i can
do right now yes
yes so i couldn't think of anything so i
went i was at the studio at laird studio
and i go into their prop department
and in their prop department the first
thing i see is there's like this 20
25 foot long giant plastic saber-tooth
tiger
you know a prehistoric tiger that so i
said
i said to i said to the guy there i said
how much
would that cost can you just put that on
the dolly
and ship it to burbank and he goes well
that's
be about 500 bucks and then there was a
i just looked up and i have no reason
why but this is kind of like the
beginning of this conversation where
i'm not giving it any thought and i
don't know why i always believe in
opportunity like maybe these things are
showing themselves to me because they're
supposed to
so there's a giant carrot so i said to
the guy could you tie the carrot on top
of the saber tooth
and then ship that to burbank and he
goes okay i'll throw that in
so then i called jim mccauley and i said
jim there's a truck coming
it's got like a 30-foot saber-tooth
tiger and a
carrot on it and uh just accept it and
it's for me and just leave it backstage
i'm gonna pull that out with me
and he goes well what's the joke i said
i don't know please
just take it and i and then they go
howie we need you on the set and they
called me and i was back on the set
i get wrapped i go down to burbank
he does his monologue it was a tough
monologue uh he
he didn't have a good set it was one of
those nights where he goes the audience
last night was so good you know but
this wasn't he had a tough time i don't
know that he was in a great mood
and they go our first guest always funny
you know him from saying elsewhere you
know him from this you know from that he
always funny howie mandel
and the audience the doc severson starts
playing music the audience
is applauding and the curtain opens they
page it back
and there i am and i got a rope and i'm
pulling this
this dolly with this giant 30-foot
saber-toothed tiger and a carrot on it
i'm pulling it toward the
toward the set through the curtain the
audience is going the music is going
and i get to the uh to the riser where
he has his desk and the couch where the
guests sit and
and the head is coming over the riser
and i try to lift the head the first
wheels
onto the the riser and i couldn't so i
say to doc
to ed and mcmahon could you help me lift
he goes
he looks at johnny okay so he's helping
me lift by this time the music has ended
and the applause is ended it's just
quiet so you hear the two of us just
kind of
lift up that but we're lifting it we
can't move it forward so i say to doc
doc is there any way you can come around
and help me like just push it so we can
get it onto the rise
so doc comes around and we're probably
30 seconds since the
applause has ended and the music has
ended and that's an eternity you know
that yeah on television of silence
and he starts pushing from the back end
so when they get the front wheels onto
the riser
the head comes up and now it's blocking
the whole desk
you can't see johnny and on these talk
shows they don't
ever really move the camera but you can
hear on the headset
you can hear the director going [ __ ]
[ __ ] camera one couple and i see them
going up and they're
like shooting down on top of johnny and
they're moving
cameras around to where they've never
had to move before and i continued to
push
to push from the back until the whole
front of the desk was blocked
and then i sit down and i'm like i'm
sweating
i'm sweating and from a weird angle
johnny is just sitting there and he's
tapping his pencil
tapping his pencil and he's looking at
me
and he goes so i go so it's great to be
here he goes
and and i go and
he goes well
what's this what is and he's pointing at
the saber tooth and the
thing and i go um
i don't want to talk about it
anyway uh i'm doing a movie now
really i said i'll talk about anything i
don't mind this is just something i
don't want to talk about
it was plucked and i could see that he
was not
you know you gotta you know that you you
show up for a show like this you don't
want to have to
work crazy hard you don't want to have
to you know everything is planned he
shows up every day
he's not he i could tell he wasn't happy
he didn't he didn't say anything to you
he didn't say
hallie this didn't work no so here's
what happened so so he goes you don't
want to talk about it now i said i uh
might be visiting my parents tomorrow or
whatever and then
finally he i could see he was mad and i
go listen my my grandmother knitted this
for me or i threw out something
he goes okay and i can't remember who
was on but he goes we'll be back with
debbie reynolds
right after this now the segment was
supposed to be longer
he so we'd go to commercial and i was
supposed to do two segments
i did one segment he said we'll be back
with debbie reynolds as soon as we went
to commercial he made no eye contact
with me
stagehands came up and they removed the
saber-tooth tiger and the carrot
he didn't say a word he was talking to
freddie to his
uh the court about his executive
producer and
uh we came back from commercial and he
said this next actress you've seen
forever and they brought out
debbie reynolds and i moved down the
couch and uh
jim mccauley said you know he doesn't
want to work with you anymore i did it
with uh
i did it afterwards with shandling and
everybody else but he didn't want to
ever
do it with me again and he never told
you why never called you nothing that
was it oh i know why i made it hard he
didn't want it just annoying he doesn't
need to
it was just that you know the same thing
happened with david letterman
you know i thought on david letterman
once i did a letter i didn't do
letterman for 15 years when david
letterman was first
at nbc and he did he was on after
johnny i went and did it i was in new
york and i sat down i just thought it
would be
and i didn't plan because i always liked
the real you know
the real discomfort and i went on there
once and i said
uh to him i'm on for about two three
minutes and i said
it's great being here in new york i have
a friend that lives here in new york do
you mind if i
say hi to him and he said no go right
ahead so i got up and left
and i never came back and the thing is
that uh
which i thought was kind of funny and
makes for maybe a story on your podcast
but
they didn't they weren't thrilled with
it
well you know what you pulled the fleet
with mac you went your own way
and and that's the whole thing i mean
you really took a chance you wanted to
be different
plus it wasn't like your first time on
carson or your 21st
time it was your 22nd time you took a
chance you thought it'd be ridiculous
and fun
it didn't work out right but here's the
thing and this is uh
this kind of ties it up nine you know
nine out of ten times for the most part
and i'm being uh
i think i'm exaggerating things don't
work yeah
but that one the way i get to that one
thing that works
is by trying the other nine things and
then
if if i try something and it doesn't
work you know they have the thing if at
first you don't succeed try try again
it should be try try try try try
try try try try try try and keep trying
until it works
and what i learned from just saying you
know i just say yes
to everything i just say i'd never say
no and no is the first two letters
nothing because nothing comes from no so
i say yes to everything that's how i
ended up i was a comedian
and then i ended up on a dramatic show i
didn't even know what that was i wanted
to do a sitcom and i ended up on st
elsewhere i was a replacement and i got
to work with denzel washington
i didn't want to get a game show host i
would have never if you
talk to any comic from the 90s or the
80s or even the early 2000s no comic
would do it we were the
punchline i mean the the the game show
host was the punchline
in comedian's uh repertoire right i was
the first one that did that it went
through the roof and now uh
i'm sure steve harvey should say thank
you howie because they after a deal or
no deal did so good then they hired jeff
foxworthy to do are you smarter than a
fifth grader
they hired louis anderson to do family
yeah
um he did one versus a hundred and then
it's always been comedians now that are
being hired to do
uh game shows but it wasn't before that
that is very true last question for you
does your hair still grow back because
then howard stern you said
that it did grow and you did it to be
clean it was more of a clean
that's when i first when i first shaved
it i was not bald i think that
since then in all my worry and all my
fear and all my old age i don't think it
would grow back
in the shape that it was in first of all
it's pure white
good you know there's [ __ ] there isn't
but i i can feel that it has receded
it has receded from where it was when i
was a young
type no i don't think it would grow i
don't think it would look great
i'd probably look like uh like my hair
would be further back like um
what's his name uh equals mc square by
uh
einstein yeah like i but it was way
further back and i'd have that
right would be interesting though hey
look you've got
this autobiography called here's the
deal don't touch me which was out a
couple years ago
which you have i'm sure you have tons of
these stories in there
more stories but more importantly you
have a new podcast
yes and it's with your daughter well so
here's the thing
just to be honest with you kind of like
you you enjoy talking to friends
i became so disconnected during covet
that
i'm sitting phoning people zooming
people talking to my daughter
just [ __ ] trying to get through each
and every day and whether
we get on the phone together me and my
daughter and do prank calls
and order [ __ ] things call want ads
um
buy products weird products offline all
the things we've been doing covid
i just with the one thing i miss is the
opportunity like a platform just to do
it on
and in lieu of everything else i'm just
loving this opportunity
even coming on other people's podcasts
yeah doing it and it's called howie
mandel does stuff
right which if we wanted to be that
specific with jacqueline schultz which
is your daughter and you guys just
pretty much
prank calls have intense conversations
funny conversations
quoting people doing just pretty much
everything we do everything we do uh
whether it's
i have friends on and guests on whether
we do prank calls or
you know we like the one ads and calling
them and trying to uh
land other careers or you know she's
also uh
she's a a teacher and an influencer and
she
does uh these reviews and unboxings and
things like that which
uh we make fun of it's just a it's just
a fun
we're just having fun challenges i love
it it's just stuff
and it's stuff i like to do and stuff
that i would normally do sometimes on
stage but i get to do it with a
family member and friends and uh
it's going to be available it is
available everywhere all right that's it
you can find it anywhere are you going
to be on youtube or is it going to just
be audio
no we haven't we're doing it are you on
youtube
i am so this will you'll be seeing we're
doing it like this yeah that's good
you gotta do it like this i love this i
didn't
know nearly as much about you as i
thought
as i just learned and these and your
stories and the way you
look at life it's sort of like i think
we're all train wrecks and it's just
like
we're just trying to stay on the tracks
or at least close to them
and you know i feel like just some of
the things you said just really hit home
and i thank you for being so open and
candid and it was uh
well thank you for giving me this
opportunity to talk to you and maybe
when this is over we can
get together in person i would love that
i would love i would love to spend some
time with you you seem like a cool guy
and i've been a fan of yours for a while
well
ditto i know
i'd like to buy a vowel uh yes that
would be and
look howie thank you for allowing me to
be inside of you and i can't wait to to
meet in person
thank you all right bye bye bye bye
i love that guy i feel like uh you know
sometimes you make friends
i feel like i could you know i emailed
howie howie i listened to
stern i heard him talk about you oh
really what
i like howie i never thought i'd like
howie that's great you just watch him on
tv and you're like
okay i don't know if i'd ever like howie
he seems i like him i don't know if i'd
ever like be friends with him
i mean you know he's a big celebrity and
you know whatever
and then you meet him and you you
interview him and
you're like hey we're just two dudes hey
two dudes two dudes that are a little
neurotic yeah did you like him
i liked him you did we had some great
stories i like those old uh
i like old showbiz stories old showbiz
stories
stories yeah i like them too so hey
thanks guys thanks for listening
and once again uh if you like the show
please subscribe
uh spotify apple it's right here uh also
on youtube
uh it's a wonderful thing it really
helps the podcast and helps us grow and
i hope you grow with us and join us
every week
remember uh my band sunspin we're
playing
on stage it go to stageit.com and get
tickets just type in sunspin
go to the inside of you online store get
lex merch smallvilles t-shirts
tons of stuff and of course sunspin.com
off type in sunspin 15 and get 15 off
all merch we've got lunch boxes and
shirts and coasters and
tons of great stuff so there's that um
my patrons thank you so much
uh i really love doing this it's it's a
lot of fun
you know sometimes i hear these
conversations on like stern and they're
talking and they have people calling all
this stuff and i think i mean i'd really
i'd like to do that i'd like to be able
to talk to ryan like you know let's get
my mom on the phone here mom why are you
[ __ ] nutty
you're like oh michael i got the thing
and i'd love to i think it would be a
really fun variety show
i think i could kill it you know have my
mom call and having like
you know and then ryan reads uh the news
here's what's in the news and
should we not do that i'm gonna read the
news well you know here are the news
clips
this is a a a headline and then we talk
about it
and then we have somebody else we call
and go what do you think about that oh
we're here with uh you know a celebrity
calling or whatever
we got some crazy person calling in oh i
just thought
tell me what you think ryan's laughing
at me uh
here we go this is the top tier patrons
these are the people that support the
podcast the most but all of you are
amazing
and appreciate you uh robert brandenburg
not forgetting you this time peggy's
cough house nancy d
mary b leah s trisha f gosh you're good
sarah v
little lisa you kiko jill e brian h
lauren g nico p
robin s jerry w robert i what could be
robert l
that's robert i it's robert i it's
capital i jeez
jason w apothean apathy and kristen k
amelia o allison l lucas amraj
c joshua d emily s cj p
whoa look at you samantha
m jennifer n jackie p stacy l
carly h gen s jamal f janelle me
ashley ryan kimberly mikey marissa and
daniello
eldon supremo dan ramirez
chad w leanne p ray a
miesha that's just myisha isn't it well
there's a last name
i don't know guess we usually only go as
far as myasia
c that's right maddie s
kendrick f ashley e shannon d matt w
belinda and kevin v
james r chris h
h dave h samantha s spider-man chase
sheila
g rey h tabitha
t wow you're [ __ ] do this
you're so good uh misha h tom and
katie f liliana a michelle k hannah b
michelle or michael michael
s talia m luke h andrew t betsy d
hi betsy claire m liz j laura l chad
l uh rochelle e nathan e brandel
taylor k neil a marion e meg k
janelle p trav l travel travel
travel what's that like i don't know dan
n jennifer j
wayne m diane r oh jetta oh yeta oh
jetta
lorraine g olga c olga c corey m
kerry h veronica k kendall t and lindsey
m
those are the top tiers those are the
folks that really help
but you all help thank you westwood one
thank you
ryan my substantially gifted engineer
slash
editor yep he is he's great and by the
way where can we find you maybe people
will follow you more what's your handle
me uh at tea is ryan
on ryan that's a at
t e t-e-l-l-e-z that's right i got
nothing to
report so i'm not posting maybe they'll
like you and they want to follow you
maybe get more followers check how many
followers you have now
we're gonna see how many followers he
has now and then we're gonna see how
many followers he has
after this airs on tuesday and he's
gonna text me and see if he has five
ten or more i'm guessing you have 138
followers yeah how many do you think i
have 138
how many i have uh 4746
4700 that's a lot
i had i had a youtube career that's
right that's right i wasn't even
thinking because you said oh it's not
many you were downplaying it
but so he's got 40. 4700 right and 6300
on instagram
okay so 4 700 and 6 300 on instagram
uh so let's see how many afterwards i've
not posted on instagram this year
all right well you might get more
followers you just never freaking know
uh this uh episode is dedicated to my
dog yerv
uh i love you buddy i love you more than
anything
and um you'll be in a better place you
had a great life
we had a lot of fun and i'll see on the
flip side buddy
from uh my home in hollywood california
i'm michael rosenbaum i'm ryan tears
welcome to the camera ryan
thank you for allowing me to be inside
of each and every one of you i
appreciate all the love all the support
of the podcast and
and me and my life so thank you